on April 26
[Music]
you know you teams you know your
missions
no mistakes no do-overs
look out for each other
this is the fight of our lives
he's pretty good at that nice adventures
and game rated pg-13 tickets on sale now
hi everyone is Charlie surprise surprise
brand-new Avengers end game trailer they
just drops we got to break it down there
are a couple things that you probably
noticed that are misleading about the
footage - they've taken a couple things
out digitally and it's easier to spot
this time because of corresponding shots
that are also in that footage we're only
a couple weeks away from it hitting
theaters we're doing that IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from all this footage on
the video there were a bunch of people
in my timeline asking me about Hulk in
this big scene where all their hands are
in the middle but I'll explain what I
think is going on here because there are
nine hands in the middle and we've only
seen eight people in that lineup when
they're walking past camera so we'll
start at the beginning of the footage
and work our way through we'll talk
about the misleading scenes - so you get
the Captain America voiceover the sort
of anchors everything saying you know
your team's you know your missions so we
know they're gonna be dividing up into a
couple different groups Scarlett
Johansson recently revealed that they
shot with at least three different
camera units in different places
simultaneously at times so there's at
least three different groups of Avengers
we've seen behind the scenes pictures of
some of the group's later in the film so
we know what some of the teams are but
not every single person so there are a
couple of people that are sort of
floating around we're not really sure
about like Thor and Captain Marvel what
are they doing later in the film while
they're flashing all this footage
talking about the teams they show you
Iron Man in his new Mark 85 with the
gold comic book arms in what seems like
the New York of the 2012 Battle of New
York during the original Avengers movie
is if this footage is taking place
during one of the quote-unquote missions
the Captain America is talking about you
get a big wide shot of an empty Avengers
hangar bay where you later see them
standing it seems like this is before
Thanos comes back and destroys the
Avengers base you get a wide shot of
them a little bit later in the film
after Ironman has come back and rejoined
them it's hard to tell exactly when this
is happening but because they have
Hawkeye with them there it seems like
it's a little bit later in the film and
rocket is wearing his comic book uniform
which he is not wearing earlier when you
see nebula and Iron Man first come back
even though a lot of this footage seems
like it's from the first hour of the
film it still seems like this is
happening much much later
even though while they're still talking
about the different teams and missions
they flashed a black widow by herself
just firing the gun
that's from a little bit earlier in the
film also kind of mixing and matching
footage from different parts of the
movie this is from part of the film
where they all start to break down a
little bit and show you how much what's
happened is wearing on them emotionally
and physically where she's trying to
calm herself down goes into target
practice of course that's something that
Black Widow would do to calm herself
down she's so messed up inside she
starts missing the target then forces
herself to double-down gets her [ __ ]
together and starts hitting it again so
it is the same for all the Avengers they
all have moments like that early in the
film then even though they show you the
suit-up moment from war machine in
ant-man they're probably other people
standing around them there that's
probably from a different part of the
film because we know that ant-man is
with Iron Man Captain America in the
Hulk so when we're talking about
different teams I don't think that war
machine and ant-man are on the same team
but the funny thing here though is that
they do show you that scene of Thor and
Captain Marvel together and even though
we know that that comes from earlier in
the film because we got that opening
scene a couple days ago there are a lot
of people that are wondering where
Captain Marvel is later in the film if
she's so big early in the film and so
overconfident about her chances of
taking Thanos all by herself of all the
theories that I've seen I do like the
idea the Captain Marvel after their
unsuccessful first attempt against
Thanos tries to go somewhere else to
rally help and bring it back and that's
why she's not around for a lot of the
film in Thor as well does the same type
of thing so like in this scene here
where you see most of the original
Avengers except for Hulk and Thor where
they add maybe Thor also goes off into
outer space to the nine realms to search
for the Asgardians and try and rally
help being the King Thor because I do
think they're trying to give them some
big seminal comic book moments and what
is one of the few things we haven't seen
Thor do yet we haven't seen him be
quote-unquote all-father Thor that much
yet it would make sense that he would
try to rally some help from them and
build an army try to bring it back
because the shatori are also a big thing
during avengers endgame and then
obviously they've been teasing this
other big threat even though I'm not
expecting a giant brand new comic book
villain to enter the mix there's still a
lot of theories about that a lot of
speculation so it's still wide open to
theory crafting but it just feels like
there's a big part of the film where
Captain Marvel isn't around because
she's off doing something else trying to
get help and will be bigger later in the
film and Thor is also playing to his
strengths he's this big cosmic character
so he's off doing cosmic
things trying to rally help that way but
then you're asking who is the ninth hand
in this circle here because we've only
seen a to them in the white suits before
when we last saw them and all those big
white suits a couple trailers ago there
was iron man
Captain America rocket war machine
ant-man Black Widow nebula in Hawkeye
those are the eight and of the other
people that it could possibly be
there's only Thor in banner because I
don't think that Captain Marvel will be
one of these people wearing one of these
white suits Kevin Feige said the whole
reason for putting them in white suits
was as they never done a moment where
all the Avengers are wearing matching
outfits that's why I think that this
extra ninth hand is either banner or
Thor and while people think that this
giant chunky fist is the Hulk's fist if
you look at the white concept art of the
Hulk suit he doesn't have any fingers on
his gloves because he's the Hulk his
suit is probably built to expand but
while he's hooked out why would he wear
gloves so I'm just assuming that if
banner is the extra hand in here that he
has not hooked out yet and it's just a
normal human sized hand or it's Thor
because we have seen Thor wearing white
suits in the concept art and all the
toys recently - hopefully that explains
why this one hand is really big though
because war machines suit is just
literally a white version of his war
machine suit it's not like Iron Man's
where it's normal size and it could just
become whatever he needs it to be you
look in the background here - there's
this weird-looking device with all these
lights on it it probably has something
to do with the quantum technology and
all the wrist devices which you see in
some of these shots but not when their
hands are in the middle so if you look
at the side here you see rocket looking
up when he was joking about Captain
America like he's really good at giving
these speeches isn't he in a man's like
yeah right you see this hand sticking
out next to rocket and it has one of
those quantum risk devices sticking out
on top of the fist but when everybody
holds their fists up they're all clean
and they're all holding their left hand
up and even though it seems like an
man's wrist device is on his right hand
so we wouldn't be seeing it in this shot
in the behind the scenes you notice the
Captain America's wrist device is on his
left hand so theoretically you should
see at least a few of these hands having
wrist devices on top of them so they
digitally remove them because they don't
want you to think about those yet but we
see them in the other shots so we know
they're gonna be a big deal during the
movie right now it seems like the teams
are gonna be based on some of the behind
the scenes and what we've seen from the
other shots and the trailers
it'll be Captain America and Iron Man
leading a team with ant-man in the Hulk
also with them
I don't know that Thor is with them
because it all seems like they're
traveling through the events of the
original Avengers movie and Chris
Hemsworth said that he had to wear a wig
during the movie this is Thor behind the
scenes while they're shooting those
scenes but just because Chris Hemsworth
shot new footage for these moments
doesn't mean that present-day Thor goes
back into the past with them it could be
the old version of Thor and Loki that
they're interacting with and it's only a
couple of the Avengers from present-day
that go back to that moment you see the
Bennet are jumping away from more rags
so either that's happening earlier in
the film or it could be part of this
quote-unquote team business that they're
all on because that's where the Power
Stone was we're still speculating about
Thor and Captain Marvel like I said they
might be off doing other things in outer
space rallying help from different
places but the one group that we don't
really know that much about our Black
Widow and Hawkeye because you see
Hawkeye running through the tunnels
which seem like they're underneath the
Avengers base running from what seems
like those four-legged dogs the
outriders when Thanos comes to destroy
the Avengers base I'm assuming that's
what this is all part of then there's
still the question of which team Black
Widow is on because we haven't seen a
lot of footage of her from behind the
scenes later in the film but she did say
something funny in a recent interview
she was doing a press junket with Danai
gurira who plays Akoya and started to
talk about how much fun it was to work
with all these other women before Danai
gurira shut her down don't give away
spoilers so it seems like Scarlett
Johansson was implying that Black Widow
is gonna be spending a lot of time with
the doora Milosh a in Wakanda or whether
or not they stay localized to Wakanda or
they come somewhere else to help out
when Captain America says no mistakes no
do-overs I also think that that's really
telling because I think that they've
lost the ability to just unsnap everyone
or just redo everything using the
Infinity Gauntlet because that is the
ultimate do-over machine we know that
this is happening much later in the film
after the first attempt at killing Panos
and taking the gauntlet so something
happens during that first fight that
renders the gullet inert either Thanos
destroys it or something happens to it
that renders it unusable so there is no
Infinity Gauntlet in present-day I know
that a lot of theories about them
constructing a second Infinity Gauntlet
it just sounds like fan OHS when he
comes back to fight him here in this
moment with this giant sword is not
wearing the Infinity Gauntlet because if
he was what
stop him from just snapping everyone
here in this moment again why would he
take the time to fight them so it just
seems like for a large portion of the at
least the middle of the film there is no
Infinity Gauntlet in existence in
present day but more to the Hulk of it
all and this big bite here I still think
the first time we see Hulk in the movie
isn't until he comes back to blow up
this base Banner is just caught in the
explosion and that's what forces him to
Hulk out that would imply that this big
fight is happening much later in the
film after the Avengers have been trying
to go on their quote-unquote missions as
Captain America calls them so by the
time phantos comes to Planet Earth
they've been at it for a little while
because you see Iron Man and his brand
new armor you see Captain America and
his scale armor from the comics so
hopefully that explains a little of the
timeline of the film early fight with
Dan oohs when they still have Captain
Marvel but do not have Hulk or Iron Man
or a couple other people like Ant Man
later in the film everyone rallies they
get the white suits the quantum energy
they figure out a way to fix the
universe because apparently at this
point there is no Infinity Gauntlet for
them to use then later Thanos catches on
to what they're doing comes to the
Avengers base to stop them from
completing their plan blows everything
up in the Avengers rally and defeat him
finally but the movie is three hours
long so that is just a drop in the
bucket there's still so much other plot
they can get out with all that time so
let me know in the comments why do you
think that the Avengers are using the
quantum suits in the quantum energy to
go travel to different places where the
Infinity stones were known to have been
like Morag where the power stone was or
during the Battle of New York where the
mind stone in the space stone were
regardless of what happens to the
Infinity Gauntlet early in the film it
still seems like the Infinity stones are
a big part of the plan even later in the
film big news this weekend is the game
of Thrones Season 8 is starting I'll be
doing videos for that obviously there'll
be more Avengers stuff happening in the
background but also Star Wars
Celebration is happening so we're
probably gonna get a star wars episode 9
trailer in the morning so of course I'll
do a video for whatever footage they
drop no worries I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post my next Marvel video
while you wait for all that click here
for my Hawkeye Avengers endgame video in
an explainer for the Hawkeye TV series
they just announced and click here to
start getting ready for Game of Thrones
season 8
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you
tonight
[Music]